ottawa todos os fios sua vida há sempre
que usam microfone deste levantamento da
nova zelândia e hoje vem cá falar vos de
pequenos problemas e grandes problemas e
porque é que os dos frios podem ajudar a
salvar a humanidade a atenção na maneira
de compensar os problemas na humanidade
podem dividir se fundamentalmente em
duas grandes categorias
temos os problemas simples e os
problemas complexos
um exemplo com problemas simples é velha
história do ovo e da galinha que a longo
e médio estava vago é a quinta de
citações discussões e até algumas
pessoas organizar conferências com esse
tema
para nós é história natural já houve
problema em tempo e portanto os
problemas que são geralmente não
acontece mais complexo
não tá em epicamente uma resposta
simples medicamento expostas várias
partes e portanto a única forma de
abordarmos um problema complexo já que o
que é vasto conhecimento da humanidade e
infelizmente a internet permite à
informação e ao investigar o problema
tentamos compreender não só o seu
contexto nas diversas partes que
constitui
o objetivo disto é nós premiados de uma
forma implícita mas melhoraram para que
o que é origem do problema está sobre a
origem do problema tem uma
característica muito especial
quanto mais perto da origem nós
resolvemos um problema tipicamente menos
recursos humanos têm tendência a
aumentar
aí qualquer esforço de prevenção
tecnicamente resultados infinitamente
melhor do que quando tentamos por
simplesmente resolver as consequências e
é por isso que quando chegamos em essas
causas primárias que acontece aqui
quando eu estou muito completo
é ter calma diretamente enxerga daquilo
que é a capacidade que cada um de nós
individualmente grande e portanto aqui
os meninos de pessoas que têm valências
de competências complementares à nossas
criar uma equipa de trabalho e então
dividir esta parte do problema em parte
mais pequenas que todos nós possa lidar
com elas individualmente um exemplo hoje
está entrando em trazer é o problema do
aquecimento global é um problema e uma
oportunidade que a primeira vez em toda
a história dominava em que nós temos um
problema de oferta enquanto espécie e é
um problema que nenhum país vai
conseguir resolver individualmente
nenhum de nós vai conseguir resolver
individualmente não vai haver uma
solução única e simples preço e como tal
tem potencial de unir a humanidade
vamos investigar um pouco conexões
causas do aquecimento global o
crescimento volta em fundamentalmente
uma grande causa que é consumido durante
os últimos 50 anos a humanidade tem
evoluído exponencialmente e essa
evolução tem sido à custa de uma de uma
coisa é uma fonte de energia que nós
pensávamos que era
o executável e que era eu sou do rio
preto ituano eram os combustíveis
fósseis
gravamos por descobrir que não só não é
indisputável como eventualmente traz um
preço extremamente o aquecimento global
poderá levar à extinção da humanidade e
portanto na abordagem do problema nós
podemos dividir as funções em duas
grandes categorias
lá temos de produção energia sustentável
que vai incluir necessariamente um
conjunto de outras funções nas quais
será geológicas um argila térmica e me
dizer muito homem também não colher e
por outro lado temos o consumo do curso
aqui evento ficarão as mais parte do
problema em consumir energia e será a
combinação das horas houve em um
problema há um problema que é algo que
nós não temos como garantir que abrimos
a torneira e temos água gesto é pra nós
completamente apresenta para ter uma
idéia 68 por cento de toda a energia que
é consumida e gasta fundamentalmente
para garantir a mão do esquema
existe um problema que é um problema de
visto unidade e discriminado e é o custo
das tecnologias que nos garantem que
quando efetivamente abre a torneira da
água quente instalar rapidamente para
ter uma idéia do impacto que está em 2,4
por cento de toda a energia que é
consumida no mundo gasta não aquecer a
água só garantir que a água está lá
quando você sabe
para ter uma idéia do que isso
representa no grande plano das coisas do
jogo 400
parece pouco mas a energia que portugal
com o solo num ano só tem portanto todos
os anos nós gastamos energia combinava
16 portugais nem sequer aquecer a água é
só garantir que a água está escolhido e
portanto uma vez identificado o problema
um pouco mais
o problema é que nós conhecemos está
longe da água e eventualmente a água
quente acaba o intuito de fornecer
energia mas em pequeno tipo de piada
existem já as funções que ingressam esse
problema já circula nos fundamentalmente
o que acontece no caso dos hotéis outras
grandes áreas muito distantes do ponto
de consumo é que estão constantemente a
aquecer a água e ao circo ao um circuito
para léo garante que quando era
imediatamente porque é que nós não é uma
forma de energia perto todos cônsul
filho já não posso dizer que neste
momento
e portanto este foi o que o contributo
que o trouxe para este problema e os que
estão hoje é isso é que escolha um
grande problema é complexo
olha com atenção não tenho medo de
ninguém porque os problemas são pequenos
quando confrontado com problemas
o vosso problema o problema não sabem
não conseguem tudo ótimo
dificilmente alguém estava com certo
arranjem sua esposa june arranje mais
esse problema por muito tempo porque
será
mas o ambiente porque os problemas do
vídeo nós vamos conseguir enquanto
espécie sobreviver às vezes temos
problemas e é por isso que eu venho aqui
dizer sejam os heróis da humanidade o
voto o eleitor precisa do concelho